well over the past month during our 4 pm
newscast we've introduced you to four
remarkable women from right here in
southern nevada they were chosen from
dozens of
nominations we received from you our
viewer but only
one could be chosen to represent our
state in a nationwide virtual event
sponsored by our parent company nextstar
our newsroom did some maneuvering to
surprise her
and denise valdez picks up the story
from there
the remarkable woman just won from las
vegas
is sitting right next to me and that is
trudy parakilman
[Applause]
the look on her face says it all stunned
and overwhelmed
oh my goodness thank you so much
as part of our surprise reveal kilman
and her family arrived at the channel 8
studios in a limousine
while finishing touches and flowers
decked out our studio
we talked with the homeless advocate
about her work
what i do everybody should be doing it's
lifting people up it's helping one
another when you're in crisis
she sat down for what she thought was
another interview
and learned she was our winner going on
to the nationwide event with dozens of
other honorees
on behalf of klas tv8 and nexstar media
group we are presenting your charity
with a check for one thousand dollars
what a story you have
you were nearly homeless you had to pick
yourself up and start the compassion
initiative lv
what else do you want anything killman's
compassion work in our community helps
hundreds of
underserved living on the streets trudy
has made it her mission
to bring light into others lives i am so
proud
to see one of our hometown heroes being
recognized those people
have rescued me as much as i have
rescued them this has given me an
opportunity to step outside of my
space and give me
a purpose after the announcement
a safely distanced luncheon allowed each
of us
to tell trudy what a remarkable woman
she is
congratulations
trudy congratulations clearly well
deserved to learn more about the women
doing remarkable work in our community
like trudy
you can watch all the stories over on
8newsnow.com